heads up nick fury's calling you that's
him
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not ghost Nick Fury
I love that guy I need a suit
I like the new suit Thanks
hello Peter hello would you like to see
what I can do
whoa
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have a new awesome spider-man far
from home TV spot as you just saw there
are some really amazing new scenes in
this TV spot so we're gonna go ahead and
break it down also a quick reminder at
the 450,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection so be sure to
subscribe to my channel and like the
video so you can enter so this TV spot
starts off with a clip that we've seen
before we're happy is telling Peter that
Nick Fury is calling and then he ignores
his call and happy says you do not ghost
Nick Fury but didn't we have some new
footage of Peter taking down the
Manfredi mob and we see some new action
from him including him using his iron
spider legs and his web blasters now
thanks to a trailer that is now playing
in theaters we know that this takes
place before spider-man goes on vacation
plus he's also wearing his iron spider
suit which we don't really see him wear
much in any of the TV spots or any of
the trailers and then we hear the cops
say I love that guy so this is actually
going to play a pretty significant part
in spider-man fire from home as we know
from the other trailers and TV spots
everybody is looking towards Peter to be
the next Iron Man and everybody is
really starting to love spider-man and
this is going to be a key point because
Mysterio wants everybody to love him
that's always been Mysterio's motive he
wants to take out spider-man so that he
can be the new hero that everybody loves
that's why we see Mysterio all
buddy-buddy with Peter he doesn't want
Peter to be spider-man anymore so I
think we'll see him try to convince
Peter to just be a teenager go after the
girl he likes and give up spider-man
then we have this awesome scene of Peter
and happy and Tony Stark's old plan
where Peter Parker is making a new
spider-man suit and as you can see there
are three different suits on the display
screen so he's probably doing a
combination of a bunch of different
suits into one and if you look at the
bottom left we can see the classic iron
spider suit from the comics the red and
gold version so that's a super cool
Easter Egg to throw in there to
reference the comics and he's making
this new suit in sort of a secret lab
that Tony had in the back of his plane
so even though Tony is no longer with us
we are still going to very much feel his
presence and spider-man far from home we
then see a new scene of happy piloting
the plane
spider-man on the outside and he says I
like the new suit and we can see that it
is now the black and red suit that we've
seen in some parts of the trailers and
then we have this really awesome scene
of Peter putting on Tony Stark's glasses
they may not be Tony's exact pair that
he wore but they are definitely the same
kind and when he puts the glasses on he
finds out that there is actually an AI
that comes with the glasses and not only
that when he puts them on he can get a
ton of information about the people that
he's looking at including what they're
doing on their phones we can see that
one of the teachers is reading a book
the history of witchcraft we can see
that another one is sending a text we
can see that one of the students is
texting his mom saying that he needs
more money and we see a little bit more
of Ned and Betty's romance they are so
in love that they're texting each other
they miss each other even though they're
sitting right next to each other so
basically these glasses that Tony Stark
had and now Peter Parker has are
essentially an AI that gives Peter a
bunch of information in analytics about
whatever he looks at this is another
really cool call back to Tony Stark and
how he's still going to be helping Peter
in spider-man far from home even though
he's no longer with us
so that's it for this new spider-man far
from home TV spot this is one of the
coolest I think that we've seen but let
me know your thoughts on this and let me
know how excited you are to see
spider-man far from home in less than a
month and another reminder about my
giveaway at the 450,000 subscriber mark
I will be picking three winners and each
will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
and I'll be starting a Twitter and
Instagram giveaway as well if you'd like
to follow me on social media as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your